I thank you so much I'm Salone Jen I'm a
rapid developer and I'm a data scientist
at Nvidia so before I get into the just
beating of machine learning in GPIOs I
just want to talk about the motivation
and the reason why we started doing it
so initially when there was Hadoop like
backtrack like maybe 10 years back
everything was had to be read from disk
and then you know you performed your
query you rolled it back to disk and
then you I'm sorry I'm can everyone hear
me I should have started with that oh oh
sorry
yeah I should have started off with that
okay I'm gonna start up again okay hi
i'm Salone chen i'm a rapid developer
and I'm a data scientist at Nvidia so
before I start off with why we need to
being of machine learning tasks and GPUs
and well using API Python I'm gonna talk
about the whole reason why we started
doing it and so initially if you
backtrack like 10 years there was Hadoop
where you used to read everything from
disk and then you performed your query
you rolled it back to disk then again
you read it back and there was like a
lot of reading right back from disk and
that would use a lot of computation
power and time and then spark was
introduced and SPARC made it much much
quicker it was less code and you just
read it from disk and everything was in
memory but now if you come back again
it's like nowadays you start seeing
issues and bottlenecks with large data
sets that we have and cheap and just
memory processing so even to do a basic
probably ETL function you might have a
bottleneck in the memory so that's why
people wanted to exploit GPUs since they
have a lot of computational power and
they're quicker but even with that you
would read it from the disk but you had
to read from the GPU and write back to
the CPU for other implementations to be
used
and so we saw an opportunity here to
reduce the read and write back and forth
and just to explain how this would take
place like how what was the issue was if
you're trying to perform an application
a you would load the application into
the GPU the application will be
performed really quickly but then you
had to copy and convert the data so that
it could be passed to CPU and then the
application will again copy and convert
the data so application B could use it
and then that would be passed into GPU
and so there's a lot of copying can work
that happens which is a lot of waste of
time and so we looked at if we could
just get how we could get rid of the
whole copying and converting back and
forth to improve the time and the
computer to use the computation required
and so what we did is using Apache Aero
as a base we created environment or an
ecosystem which which is basically what
you does initially read your data in and
then perform everything on the GPU so
your query ETL and machine learning
training there's no copying and
converting between the data and so once
you implement this you see that you get
a lot of speed up so here what we did is
just to show you how much speed up you
get
we created an end-to-end model on the
mortgage data set which was around a 200
GB CSV file and the whole point of this
data set was to see if well - to see if
someone would default on the mortgage or
not and so we perform basic basic like
slicing and dicing of the data set and
then we trained it using an extra boost
model and if you see this there's an
extreme speed up when you use just a
single dgx - which is a 16 GPU box or if
you use five a GPU boxes you get massive
speed ups
so but even if you get these speed ups
if you actually have to change your
entire code or you have to learn a new
basic core language like if you have to
learn CUDA that's too much of a hassle
and probably not really convenient so
our main objective was to speed it up
but also to keep it within a familiar
environment and so we use the PI data
ecosystem and modeled it on the
libraries that everything like you know
is familiar everyone's familiar with
like pandas for data analytics then you
have scikit-learn for machine learning
you have network x4 graph analytics and
so on so we created kudi fko which is
similar to pandas API which is Fertitta
analytics and we have COO ml which is a
similar API for machine learning cool
graph which has which is similar to
using Network X and now for KU ml which
is basically the library that I firmly
work on I'm gonna just introduce it a
little bit give you an idea of what it
is and then we're gonna take a deeper
dive into random forests so equipment
library like I mentioned before is just
it has the similar API as I could learn
and it's a GPU it has GPU accelerated
machine learning algorithms on it and
the reason why we did it is because the
datasets nowadays are just they just
keep growing and growing in size and
what we need to do is if you're trying
to just use your data and put it in
machine learning algorithm it's gonna
take forever to train and it's gonna be
even worse when you're just doing
performing hyper parameter tuning
because that's gonna take forever to do
so people tend to perform histogram
distributions dimensionality reduction
and other like remove the outliers and
other patterns and algorithms just to
get the data size and probably a smaller
contained version so your training and
testing is within a reasonable speed and
takes a reasonable time so just under
well I look under the hood for ku M L is
that we have a bitin sight in there and
a full and full-featured C++ layer and
what I would like to specially mention
here is we have something called cou ml
prims which just contains the primitive
mathematic algorithms which is used in a
lot which is used for building a lot of
machine learning algorithms so we
actually expose these prims so in case
someone wants to do something different
and not just use a basic not just use a
basic machine learning algorithm like
tweak it up so you can instead of
writing the whole CUDA code you can just
use these primitive algorithms and you
go from there so some of the algorithms
if we have in KU m l that we actually
provide our learning
sorry decision trees random forest for
classification regression we have
multiple for inference clustering
decomposition and dimensionality
reduction but what I would like to
highlight here as well is we have
something for analyzing your time series
data like Holt winters and Kalman
filtering we're also soon gonna be
releasing well actually next week we're
gonna be releasing a point 11 version
which is gonna have a multi node
multi-gpu versions of a lot of these
algorithms in it and we're working on
adding cross validation hyper parameter
to name to QM a library as well so now
random forests
well random forest is very famous and a
bell light algorithm in the data science
community and just an introduction to it
in case someone's not familiar with
random forests it just consists of
multiple decision tree models and each
of these models are trained independent
of the other and each tree is trained
using samples that are picked from the
training dataset but these samples are
picked with replacement and a random set
of the features for these data sets is
selected without replacement when you're
trying to split at the nodes and what
happens is since you have multiple
different decision trees which are used
which are trained on different data
like which train on different parts of
the data set it prevents you from
overfitting your model and that's why
generally random forest is really liked
sorry sorry so when you're building the
random forest the most important part is
how you split at the node and you create
the branches and while you're creating
you have two choices one is the feature
which is important and the other is the
split value that you choose and so
generally in KML we support flow for
split criterias or metrics that you
would use is Gini index and entropy
which is used for classification and
then you have mean square error and mean
absolute error which are used for
regression models now this is basically
even used but how do you actually speed
it up so in order to speed it up we have
split calculation algorithms which will
help you us in accelerating which is
either we can use quantiles or min max
histogram algorithm and what this does
is it reduces the work which is required
for the split computation and compares
into just an exhaustive search which is
generally done so I'm talking a little
bit more about these algorithms
it's the min/max algorithm what happens
here is the user generated by creating
the model will provide us with two
information two important information as
one as the split criteria which was the
quanta which was the Gini index or the
entropy or the MS your mean absolute
error that someone would want to use and
the second one which we use is number of
bins and what happens is the histogram
for the features is created and for each
tree node and the data range for each
feature so the min and the max is
equally split into the number of bins
given by the user and what this helps us
to do is it helps us to weed out any and
isolate any of the outliers that would
be there
and generally once you have created the
bins for each bin we take a potential
value split value is generally the
maximum value of that been in the
quantile algorithm so what we do is the
number of bins that are defined is used
slightly differently and first we're
going to actually take all the features
and we sort them in an ascending order
and then these assorted feet sorry and
Fiza
these sorted features are then split
into pens and each bin instead of being
split on based on the features is
actually spaced split based on the
number of datasets sorry number of
samples and so what happens is each bin
has equal number of samples but each bin
does not have equal number of features
in it so and then this is a much faster
approach than using histogram algorithm
because what we do here is we always
preach we always compute the feature of
the tree only once which is at the tree
node and so this is much quicker than
using histogram but each of these has a
little bit of drawbacks
so histogram will be more accurate since
you keep doing it at each position and
it also helps you weed out outliers if
you know your data set has more outliers
it makes more sense to use a histogram
approach then a quantile approach so we
have a multi node multi-gpu version of
the random forest algorithm and what we
do here is we use tasks in order to
implement it so first task is actually
going to distribute your data to the
gpo's and then we use the training so
then we split the data so the data can
either be replicated and then the same
copy is given throughout to all the GPUs
are the better way and the more
efficient way of doing it would be to
split the data randomly so you're gonna
split the data randomly and the random
data is going to be given to all the
other two ought to eat GPU to create the
decision trees and when you do that it's
basically the same
same approach that's taken for creating
an normally random forest where you have
the data set and you create and use the
features while the inferencing here we
perform on CPU because right now we're
still working on the GPU version of the
inferencing but for here inferencing
what we have is a cpu implementation and
so a GPU calls the product independently
and then you get your predicted results
and for classification you either
perform a voting on the results or for a
question you're just gonna take an
average of it and hopefully we're
planning to release and you'll be able
to release that MMG for the prediction
for MMG on GPUs in point 12 release
which should which is around Jan
mid-january so I mentioned we have a KU
ml like CPU version of the products so
we also have a GPU version where in
order to do that we use a library which
we created called a forest inference
library and this is since it's an
inference library it's not weak you can
not only just use it for random forests
but you can also use it for XJ post Lite
GBM models or protobufs I can learn
random forests also so if you have a
saved model you can just a sec to learn
random forest model and you want to load
it and use the GPU for inferencing you
can use the forest inference library
load your model and use it as well
and here on the side you can see we have
the time comparison so we train an extra
boost model and the model had like
thousand trees and we compared the time
required for a CPU to do the prediction
and the GPU and you can see that there
is a big difference and speed right now
if you have already trained a random
forest you're like okay I don't want to
waste time training another one because
if your dataset is too big you're gonna
be like yeah that's not worth it so just
specifically for random forests the
pickling was slightly tricky so what we
did was internally we trained the model
and then are you passing a trained model
but if we convert to a tree light format
and tree light is a open source library
that we use as a base for a forest in
France library we actually considered
creating our own base but that was
another hole well it was a lot of work
and tree like we experimented with tree
line worked really well so we decided to
go for it and so what we do is we create
our random forest to a tree light format
and within tree light we use it has a
function called
export to protobuf so the model from
tree light is actually exported to a
protobuf format and once it's exported
to offer a format in a file we read the
file and save the file data as model
bytes so ultimately what happens is
these model bytes are the ones that are
saved and so when you are actually gonna
be picked
once you're when you're actually going
to be trying to pickle your random
forests from qu ml it will read these
model bytes and the model bytes are then
again converted to a protobuf mark sorry
the model bytes are written to a file
and this file since it was initially a
portable file it has come it is read as
a protobuf format and then once the
portable format is read using the tree
light function that's passed into a
forest inference library and then you
the first inference library performs a
prediction and you get your results even
though I know it's a lot of steps but
there is almost no difference in time
okay
this is one of our notebooks on github
for them this is just going to talk
about the random forest classification
and pickling okay so one important thing
I want to show here is how easy it is to
use cout ml so from cycle learn like if
you see the way we import it oh my god
oh I'm sorry I thought that was actually
on do i oh yeah no but how do I go to
this no but this is true this is not in
my presentation this was a link so I
clicked on the legs
oh the spring okay sorry about that okay
yeah all right
so here what I wanted to highlight is
it's because I actually don't have time
to run it live but the important thing
here I wanted highlight is how easy it
is if you already have code which is
using socket learn to just use cou ml in
it is when you see when you're importing
is right here it's I could learn
ensemble random forest classifier and
for cou ml it's the same thing all you
have to do is replace the sk learn with
KU ml and we have been loading your data
of to raise to 17 size and we create so
this is just based on random forests
this is just using random data so you
just use a psychic learns function make
classification to create the data set
and um right now we're gonna pass
through a random forest classification
model and I'm also going to show you
pickling but yeah so uh does the host
you train it and when you have the time
you should really just go to this
function and you should try the notebook
because when we ran it scikit-learn
takes yes
oh is that better
do you want me to go to the top no okay
so here the cycles are more like we're
creating like 40 40 trees and you have
each trees of a depth 16 and you just
said a random stay and you'll see it
takes minutes to run the socket learn
model for this data set but when you're
actually running into on qml it runs in
a few seconds and we've kept everything
the same the yeah and also for
prediction when you're actually doing
pickling it's the same pickling you
would be doing if you're actually just
pickling a psychic learning model there
is no difference at all so you would
import the pickle
your typical down and so you can either
dump it into a wearable or you can just
create a file name and you can dump it
into a file name and then read it from
there
okay so now some of the trade-offs of
using KU ml over scikit-learn
and some of the limitations that we have
so first of all when we perform pickling
and you perform pickling for random
forests regression models since we're
doing it in GPU and we have a lot of
prowl processing going on the results
aren't always exactly reproducible and
what I mean by that is if your test case
has ten where ten samples in it so nine
of them would be exactly the way it was
for the previous model but when you're
the tenth one would be slightly off to
you to parallel processing and in random
forests classification right now forests
inference library just supports binary
class classification we're working on
multi-class classification but it's
still a work in progress and the best
way to get the most out of Co ml would
be if you have a larger data set if you
can really see the time difference when
you're using it for Cusack when you're
using scikit-learn on it or when you use
Q ml and the second one is using fill
for regression so for inference library
for profusing prediction on regression
models
it's amazing speed-up and even though
binary classification works really well
and the next one I would say is when
you're well the split acceleration the
split and algorithm use for acceleration
if you actually use if you know your
data set and you know you might have
outliers in it it makes more sense to
use a histogram algorithm in it but if
not the quantile algorithm is much
quicker and there is very little
difference in accuracy if you see and
right now we had released our point and
version in October 2019 and like I said
we have our point 11 coming next week so
well these are some of the features that
we have and we have introduced we have
added a lot of Eminem's multi-node
multi-gpu algorithms for the next
release in and somewhere like hopefully
in march 20 20 we hope to be
down with the multi-node multi-gpu
versions of almost all algorithms other
than a few and if you were interested in
using Rapids it's super easy we have a
github it's all open source it's we have
a github length we have get up page
which has all the cool in there we also
if you don't want to build it from
source there's an Condor packages that
you can just do Condor install for and
we also have docker hub containers so if
our main sorry our main website is
Rapids a Icom and if you go to that you
on new scroll all the way to the bottom
of the page this is something that we
created which would be even make it
super easy for you to pick what you
wanted to install them because I have
used a lot of libraries when I was
studying and always setting them up was
a big pain like setting them up getting
them working always was a big pain
so we've tested it and you just do that
and you have it in your environment it's
super easy and if you are more of
container person docker containers are
also like if you select that it will
give you instructions on how to do it
this is our Rapids AI page where we have
all the code there if anyone's
interested and we also have
documentation zat dock stop it's da da I
where you'll be able to see the
different variables you can use and we
have tried to keep it as similar to a
socket learn as possible but there are
since we do perform the process of the
video implementing algorithms in a
slightly different way in order to speed
it up there is like variations and we do
have additional variables or there are
certain variables that we do not support
so I would definitely suggest going to
the documentation and also reading that
and then it's like I mentioned it's all
open source so if you're interested in
contributing you can always want to be
active Rapids or these are some of the
other projects that you could contribute
to and help thank you
[Applause]
questions yeah thank you very
interesting talk
the just so I'm clear the the docker
containers that we could experiment with
those do those actually provide any GPU
resources if you don't have a GPU of
your own machine yeah no you need a GPU
for the docker containers but um you're
gonna need TP for using the docker
containers okay yeah sorry
it's
I saw that the influence time using the
GPU libraries like 34 times faster I'm
sorry could you the influence is 34
times faster using the GPU library most
sorry yes I use in the extra boost yes
but the problem with using GPU sitting
influence time is they are really really
expensive because most of the companies
would want to use some deploy something
on AWS or Microsoft or Google so do you
think there is some parity between or
there is some incentives incentives for
companies or data scientists to use GPUs
for inference instead of CPUs just
because of the cost it takes well this
is just not just for infant I mean this
is for inferencing and the speeds of
inferencing but we also have like for
training so we have actually boost in
different models that you can use for
training this is more like if you've
already trained a model and you don't
want to waste time training it all over
again right so this is there's more like
in the pickling format that you can just
take your model and then use it for
inferencing okay thank you does that
answer your question I think so yeah
okay cool right there
so what about all the platforms ones
that disconnected from the clouds
do you have solutions for that like all
machines or clusters I'm asking for a
reason because those still exist so just
disconnected from cloud yes things that
work outside the cloud like things that
even don't have docker
can you help those well so you can
you're gonna have Conda right yeah so we
have Conda so we have packages for Conda
so it's literally Conda install COO ml
or Conda install Kodi F so you can use
those to create your environment so and
the last slide the second I'll just oh
right there
so you can but here we also have docker
I'm sorry Conda this is the Conda
install so if you can just easily pick
which version do you want so we have two
version which is stable and nightly
stable is the released version and
nightly is the one that we release like
every night we update the containers for
the current developing code so it's like
if we release if you're working on some
model and you want it you can go to the
nightly one and get it and you just pick
your packages and that's a Conda install
that you have so you don't need a
container to actually play around or use
Rapids you can just create an
environment on your system do a Conda
install you have everything there to do
it
I would like to write a monk oh that
cute with qml and all the stuff just
simulate the running using a GPS
simulation make sure everything runs
properly into end and then I can fire a
pair you know some instance which has a
lot of GPUs and then make sure that just
run it there without without any issues
I don't want to be experimenting and
failing and experimenting expenses you
have any kind of simulators available or
how do you how do you experiment oh for
just using CPUs no using using CPUs but
it should be like you should be able to
use the GPU code on CPUs exactly
simulator which is basically an end to
end and then I can I'm a varus I'm
really I don't think so
but I can double check it and then if
you like I can talk to you later and
then I can let you know
hey beyond these famous packages for
data browsing right like nyeh Ponder's
right so that is traditionally used for
all the CPU processing so when I want to
adapt my code to kill emergency you know
do I have to rewrite my course
especially for the data processing steps
to adapt to the processing know so like
I said we try to keep the API similar so
all you would have to do is like in case
of pandas if you want to use Korea for
like ETL processing all you do is just
replace the PD like with the coup DF and
that's it and for coup ml you replace
your SK learn wherever so if you do
import sq learn and then you have like
random forest classifier here so all you
have to do in order to use it is just
replace but you have s killer and being
imported to KML
so you just change one word and that's
pretty much it yeah so from most that
should be it and like if you want to see
like if you want to do some other
variations like with the KU ml model
then you can see the documentation to
see what all you can add to it
the ETL right so pre processing of the
data data making the data ready for the
model and itself like takes a lot of
time right yeah so how do you do any of
your packages yeah so cou DF is similar
to what you have a pandas so that's for
your pre-processing your ETL what you do
like what you mentioned right like the
whole cleaning up anything that you want
to do on that so before you actually add
it to a deep layer machine learning
model so all of that what you do with
pandas you can do it with curry we have
similar API for that so you can just
replace pandas with cou TF and you
should be good hi my question was what
does it take to extend it so if you
wanted to implement your own like random
forest classifier you write in CUDA or
is there simpler way using the the cool
params so cool prints basically would
give you the basic mathematical require
requirements that you would need but
there is also like since co-princes in
c++ so you wouldn't need to do a c++
aware of it and so in that we don't have
everything exposed to python we just
have the genuine ones that I used like
probably distance algorithms or like
some of the normal linear algebra that's
required vanna force is much more
complicated so for a random forest you
would have to if you want to change it
up or do something else you would have
to do it in C++ but for others since
which you have the general ones that are
required and a bunch of machine learning
algorithms we have those exposed but for
the others you would have to do C++ you
don't need to do CUDA because you
already have it in prims so you need to
do C++ but you don't need to do CUDA
programming yeah
and the other question was I know noon
book and target GPU is the planned inner
compatibility with that to be able to
bring something like a GPU kernel and so
for in qu ml ogre in qml models we do
support number qu pi numpy dealer that
you can import us so we support yeah and
we support Cooley F of course so all of
these datasets are supported and yeah
any other questions all right thank you
so much
[Applause]